just as Paul rudlo put forward 57
recommendations when he said the federal
government was justified in their
unprecedented use of the emergencies act
to break up the freedom Convoy protest
Public Safety Minister Dominic LeBlanc
has now sent the six-month status update
to the Prime Minister and the running
theme this is still very much a work in
progress
the Convoy protest took over downtown
Ottawa for three weeks last year half of
rulo's recommendations focus on policing
saying a series of missteps from local
police municipal government and a lack
of provincial support led to an
initially lawful protest spiraling out
of control LeBlanc writes the RCMP is
working to improve information sharing
between policing agencies plus reviewing
command and control models to ensure it
can integrate with other police agencies
during a time of Crisis the border
blockades on Windsor's Ambassador Bridge
and the Coots border crossing in Alberta
were used as part of the government's
rationale for invoking the ACT LeBlanc
writes the transportation Ministry began
work this summer to examine Emergency
Management at Key Crossings and pieces
of Transportation infrastructure rullo
also called the 30-year-old act out of
date for what a modern emergency can be
LeBlanc says recommendations related to
modernizing this legislation are being
given quote a thoughtful response part
of the modernity of the Convoy protest
was how it spread online among
recommendations to address myths and
disinformation LeBlanc points to
recently creating new programs from the
feds partnering with academics one new
thing in the update a National Security
Council for ministers to probe security
matters now it's not clear though what
could be shared there that can't be
shared at cabinet or the incident
Response Group the government's full
response is due on February 17th next
year one year after rulo's report David
Baxter Global News
Ottawa